[Music]
welcome back to London I am on
westminster bridge and this makeshift
memorial is a reminder of the terrorist
attack that took place here in March and
if you look right across the way those
barriers a not-so-subtle reminder of how
life has changed forever when I sat down
today to talk with transformer star Mark
Wahlberg I asked him about the
resiliency of this city and how much it
reminds him of his hometown of Boston
bringing the premier here what does it
say and what are the parallels between
this city and your city of Boston it
just just said you know we're gonna
continue to go out there and live our
lives and we're gonna you know good is
gonna continue to prevail it's nice to
see how strong and resilient people are
that's something mark does really well
help a city heal he starred in patriots
day all about the Boston Marathon
bombing before going straight into
production for the fifth Transformers
it's the softer side of him we don't
always get to see you mentioned your
prayer time how important is that every
day that's the most important thing I
start with that and I'm good
good for the rest of the day what does
it help do uh it just look I just wish
that I had done it when I was younger I
think would have helped me to make
better choices fast occlusive right now
come on man be careful
marks back for his second turn in the
Transformers franchise the last night
with co-stars Josh Duhamel and Anthony
Hopkins what did you do to get in shape
for this movie I started working out
like crazy I was on a strict diet but
then I would still to keep my golf game
going I play golf in the morning but
then I would run on the golf course
so I'd hit the ball and run speed golf
and so ran about seven eight miles every
day and then go to work but the most
important role for mark being dad to his
four kids including youngest daughter
Grace your daughter had a cute little
Instagram where she was imitating the
cash me out girl
oh what'd she give me I was a head area
I didn't see that on my being she might
get in trouble for that she might get in
trouble for that
yeah instead of is it inappropriate and
when it comes to older daughter Ella one
wrong move and there will be
consequences that phone will be bye-bye
oh you yank the phone oh yeah absolutely
that phone be gone she's here in London
right now with no issue she's at the
hotel so it's just that phone's close by
[Music]